Dr. Scholl's.
Born to Move.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: SPECULATING ON THE
HEALTH OF MELANIA TRUMP.
CNN IS DOING THIS.
A LOT OF THE DRIVE-BYES ARE.
THEY ANNOUNCED SHE HAD KIDNEY
SURGERY, A BENIGN MASS WAS
REMOVED.
THEY SAID ALL IS WELL.
AND MELANIA TRUMP WAS SPOTTED IN
THE WHITE HOUSE YESTERDAY.
THE GOLD STAR FAMILY EVENTS AND
LOOKED PERFECTLY FINE.
WALKING IN LOOKED PERFECTLY
NORMAL.
THE DRIVE BY SPECULATED, WAIT A
MINUTE.
WHAT IF TRUMP BEAT HER UP ON
FEDERAL PROPERTY.
CAN HE GET AWAY WITH BEATING UP
HIS OWN WIFE BECAUSE HE RUNS THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH?
THESE GUYS ARE TRYING TO HAVE
THIS INTELLIGENT ARGUMENT
WHETHER OR NOT TRUMP CAN BE
SUBPOENA OR PARDON HIMSELF OR
WHAT HAVE YOU.
>> Sean: THAT WAS RUSH LIMBAUGH
POINTING OUT HOW CORRUPT THE MED
POINTING OUT HOW CORRUPT THE M D
MEDIA IS.
A BRAND NEW BOOK JUST OUT TODAY.
I READ IT.
IT'S AMAZING.
"TRUMP'S AMERICA, THE TRUTH
ABOUT OUR NATION'S GREAT
COMEBACK."
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE NEWT
GINGRICH IS LIVE FROM A BOOK
STORE IN ENGINEER.
-- NEW JERSEY.
IT'S A RUN AWAY BEST HIT.
501 DAYS IN.
YOU GO THROUGH WHAT IS A MASSIVE
AMERICA COMEBACK.
THE MEDIA NEVER REPORTS IT.
WHY?
>> WELL, BECAUSE AS YOU POINTED
OUT EARLIER IN THE SHOW, THERE
IS A PSYCHOSIS OF HOSTILITY
COMING FROM ELECTION NIGHT AND
GETTING WORSE.
THEN TRUMP INTENSIFYS IT BECAUSE
HE TWEETS EVERY MORNING.
THEY WAKE EVERY MORNING AND GO
OH MY GOD, HE IS STILL
PRESIDENT.
YOU END UP WITH THE SICKENING
STUFF THAT WAS JUST CITED.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW SICK THIS IS
AND THE NASTY THINGS SAID ABOUT
MELANIA TRUMP, PUT IN THE WORD
MICHELLE OBAMA.
IMAGINE HAD ANYBODY IN THE
8-YEAR PERIOD SAID THE VILE
THINGS AND MADE THE SUGGESTIONS
THAT HAVE MADE.
IT TELLS YOU THE PATHOLOGY THAT
IS SWEEPING THROUGH THE AMERICAN
NEWS MEDIA AND THE AMERICAN
ENTERTAINMENT CULTURE.
MELANIA TRUMP DESERVES BETTER
THAN.
>> Sean: OH, YEAH.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DISGUSTING.
THEY HAVE LOST THEIR MINDS.
YOU SAID IT HAPPENED AT 10
O'CLOCK, A MASS PSYCHOSIS THAT
CONTINUES.
>> I LISTENED EARLIER.
I THOUGHT, I THINK THAT WAS MY
LINE ORIGINALLY.
>> Sean: I TOTALLY STOLE IT BUT
GAVE YOU CREDIT SO PEOPLE KNOW
IT'S TRUE.
AN IMPORTANT POINT.
YOU GO THROUGH CHAPTER BY
CHAPTER REALLY HOW PROFOUND AND
HISTORIC THIS PRESIDENCY AND HOW
MUCH SUCCESS WE HAVE HAD.
THEN YOU HAVE PART 2 OF YOUR
BOOK.
PART 2 IS THE DANGERS THAT THE
PRESIDENT FACES STARTING WITH
THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA.
GIVE US A TASTE OF THAT.
>> WELL, LOOK, THE PRESIDENT
FACES -- FIRST LET ME SAY, THE
SUCCESS OF THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SO ENORMOUS.
JUST ONE THING THAT CAME OUT
TODAY.
THEY ANNOUNCED TODAY THERE ARE
MORE JOB OPENINGS IN THE UNITED
STATES THAN THERE ARE PEOPLE
LOOKING FOR WORK.
NOW, THAT IS SUCH AN ENORMOUS
CHANGE FROM THE OBAMA YEARS AND
FROM THE BUSH YEARS.
IT'S ALMOST REVOLUTIONARY HOW
MUCH HE ACCOMPLISHED IN 500
DAYS.
THAT IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
ACHIEVEMENTS.
THE CHALLENGES ARE STILL THERE.
I THINK IT WILL BE INTERESTING
TO SEE IF THE PRESIDENT CAN
FOCUS IN.
THE PRESIDENCY IS SO BIG AND SO
ALL CONSUMING, YOU CAN LOSE YOUR
FOCUS ON OCCASION.
HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB WITH
DEREGULATION AND CONSERVATIVE
JUDGES.
THE TAX CUTS ARE WORKING AS WE
THOUGHT THEY WOULD IN MAKING
AMERICA MUCH MORE COMPETITIVE.
NOW HE IS CONFRONTING THE DEEP
STATE IN A FOUND WAY.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: WILL WEIN?
>> PROBABLY.
BECAUSE TRUMP IS A REMARKABLE
LEADER.
WE SHOULD UNDERSTAND
UNDER-ESTIMATE THE BUREAUCRACY
AND THE INTEREST GROUPS THAT
WANT TO AVOID THE CHANGES TRUMP
AND PENCE WANT OR THE PENTAGON
WANTS TO SPEND MONEY ON THE OLD
THINGS THAT MAKE THEM HAPPEN OR.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT IS
DESPERATELY TRYING TO AVOID THE
TRUTH.
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THE SYSTEM
IS MORE DEEPLY CORRUPT THAN ANY
OF US COULD IMAGINE.
AS IT IS COMING OUT IN THE OPEN,
ELEMENT OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, AND THE FBI, WERE
CORRUPTED ON A SCALE THAT IS
REALLY A THREAT TO THE WHOLE
AMERICAN SYSTEM.
>> Sean: WHERE ARE THE MEDIA IN
THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN OUR
LIFETIME?
WE KNOW WHAT THE CONCLUSION IS
SUPPOSED TO BE IN THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO GET IT IN
MARCH AND APRIL.
ARE THEY GOING TO BURY?
TWO WEEKS ROB ROSENSTEIN AND
COMPANY HAD OPPORTUNITIES TO TRY
AND GET THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
SOFTEN THE BLOW AND MAKE
CHANGESES AND CLAIM THEY NEED
REDACTIONS FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> I DON'T EXACTLY SHARE YOUR
WORRY.
THIS REPORT WILL BE SO BIG AND
SO DEVASTATING --
>> Sean: WHY DO YOU HAVE FAITH
IN THAT WE KNOW HILLARY CLINTON
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE AND THE
INVESTIGATION WAS RIGGED.
WE HAVE KNOWN THAT FOR A WHILE.
>> RIGHT.
THE NUMBER 2 MAN IN THE FBI IS
NOW UNDER CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
THE NUMBER 1 MAN WILL BE UNDER
CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
THESE THINGS ARE GRADUALLY
COMING OUT.
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM IS GRINDING
AWAY DESPITE THE FACT WE HAVE AN
UNBELIEVABLY WEAK ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND A DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO IS THE DEEP STATE
AND I THINK IS TOTALLY
UNRELIABLE.
YOU HAVE A WITCH HUNT LED BY
ROBERT MUELLER WHICH BROUGHT IN
ANTI-TRUMP LAWYERS SOME OF WHOM
HAVE TERRIBLE RECORDS OF ABUSE.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE OUT
THERE.
MAYBE BECAUSE I AM A NAIVE
OPTIMIST, I BELIEVE THE AMERICAN
SYSTEM WORKS OVER TIME.
>> Sean: I HOPE YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> THE LEVEL OF CORRUPTION WOULD
BE UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Sean: NOT ANY MIDDLE GROUND
IN THIS.
I WANT TO SAY YOUR BOOK IS THE
DEFINITIVE BOOK THAT EXPLAINS
THE PRESIDENT'S SUCCESS IN 500
DAYS AND REAL CHALLENGE THE
PRESIDENT FACES FROM THE DEEP
STATE AND THE MEDIA.